Fox News contributor former Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo is back with us you
know Mr secretary in in my mind my heart
my soul I I just fundamentally know that
dealing making a deal for hostages will
likely in the end result with more
hostage taking that's what I believe
however with that said I do believe
Israel is doing the right thing uh they
care about their citizens they have an
opportunity the deal is about as unfair
as any as you can get but if I was a
family member I know what I would want
do I believe in my heart it's probably
the wrong thing to do probably but you
got to hope and pray that that will
eventually lead for the opportunity for
Israel to finally take out
Hamas well Sean it's a horrific decision
that the leadership in Israel is had to
make I suspect um they they have a plan
uh they are not naive uh unlike our
president they understand understand
that Iran is behind this and that
they've got to wipe Hamas from the face
of Gaza and that they will I'm confident
that they're going to do everything they
can to get every one of these prisoners
home and then they're going to complete
the necessary they're going to do that
hard work they're going to take Hamas
out they're going to create a security
architecture for themselves where they
never have to face this again from the
Gaza Strip and they won't be silly
enough to put the Palestinian Authority
in charge in Gaza they won't be silly
enough to ever underestimate Hezbollah
they're going to do the things they need
to I I wish our president was as serious
of protecting the American people and
our soldiers Sailors Airmen and Marines
as I'm confident the Israeli leadership
is going to be to protect their own
citizens in Israel but we all know
what's happening during this ceasefire
they are rearming they are recalibrating
their war strategy uh they are reupping
their supplies so this pause gives them
an opportunity to reconfigure how they
are going to approach Israel in the in
the future does that hurt Israel's
efforts to wipe out
Hamas it'll make it harder it'll make it
last longer but I'm confident the
Israelis will still figure their way
through this they uh they've got to
confront this the the very reason that
they took these hostages is to the point
you made earlier Sean uh we know they'll
take more hostages if they don't get
this right uh they'll the hum us guys
the Iranian guys they'll they'll rearm
they'll refit they'll regroup but the
Israelis will do the same they're
they're watching they're figuring this
out I'm very confident it it may be more
costly it may be a more difficult
conflict because the pause they took to
get these citizens home
um I I I I can't think of any other
decision they could have possibly made
in the face of the political pressure
and the the enormity of getting these
citizens home to their families I'm
confident the Israelis will get this
right but they're going to need time
Sean and I think President Biden has
been tougher on the Israelis than he's
been on Hamas in the sense that he has
put pressure on them at every turn to to
remind them of their duties to
international law instead of saying nope
you got a job to do go do it it's in the
benefit of not only the citizens of of
Israel it's good for America it's good
for the people living in Gaza and it's
good for the entire region the Arab the
Arab Gulf States as well Hamas being
gone is good for the entire world Mr
secretary I have a lot of sources in
Israel you know I've been in those
Terror tunnels I've been to border uh
towns in Israel with Gaza uh I know I've
been there during during flareups uh and
I'm really having a hard time because my
sources all confirm what you just said
and that is especially behind the scenes
uh publicly Biden is saying one thing
behind the scenes he saying something
very different he's putting massive
pressure on the Israelis in terms of
what they can do about ceasefires and
now he apologized according to a report
to Muslim American leaders because he
dared to question the death toll put out
by Hamas and what's amazing about this
is their history is one of
using civilians as human Shields their
history is firing Rockets from schools
and from hospitals their history of
propaganda was to blame Israel for for
shooting a uh blowing up a hospital that
was never blown up and killing 500
innocent uh doctors nurses and patients
that never died and the media in this
country ran with it so I'm I'm trying to
understand why would he make that
apology
today it's incomprehensible Sean I still
doubt everything that Hamas says
including the death casualty figures
that they have put forward and we know
this too those casualties that have
taken place are direct result of the
terror the barbaric Terror that took
place on October 7th Israel had no
intention of going into Gaza indeed they
left in 2006 they've only gone into Gaza
now because they've got to do the thing
that will protect the Israeli citizens
in the years ahead and so I can't for
the life I me figure out why President
Biden would apologize for doubting
something that Hamas says I don't
believe a word they say I don't believe
them with respect to these hostages Sean
I'm afraid they'll go back at it again
just just as the Iranians did right we
gave $6 billion dollar in Ransom to the
Iranian regime to get five Americans
home and there are now more than five
Americans held by the Iranians today uh
we're only rewarding that bad behavior
it is a terrible situation and we've got
to make sure we punish not only Hamas
but that the Iranians are punished too
if we don't do that Sean we'll still
have missiles being fired at our
soldiers all throughout the Middle East
we'll have Americans under Threat all
across the world as well Mr secretary
last question and I've asked you this
before for me we have to Define what
real Victory would be wouldn't that mean
that gazda can no longer be a launching
pad for Rockets into Israel moving
forward but wouldn't that also have to
include that Lebanon and hisbah that
they could no longer launch missiles
from the north into Israel and wouldn't
it have to mean on some level that the
the head of the snake Iran is dealt with
in some
capacity yes Sean all three of those
have to take place Israel can never go
back to the situation where they can be
threatened with artillery that sits
right across its border whether whether
that is from uh the Gaza Strip whether
that is from Southern Lebanon from
Hezbollah whether it's from the the
houthi Rebels the terrorists in Yemen or
the terrorists that sit in the
Palestinian West Bank as well no Israel
is going to have to do that and then the
United States is going to have to lead a
coalition to reisolate Iran the same way
it was for four years when we were in
office Sean isolate Iran build Out
friends and allies in the region and
make sure that Iran doesn't continue to
be the world's largest state sponsor of
Terror it is doable and each of those
things must be accomplished I remind
people you were part of the effort when
President Trump was in office of taking
out solomani uh number one state sponsor
of Terror that would be Iran secretary
Pompeo thank you as all hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else